quand vous êtes seul avec vous-même
victoria abril vous êtes fière de vous
vous êtes contente de vous je me demande
même pas j'ai pas le temps mais on va le
faire on va faire une interview
monologue
[Musique]
victoria abril donc là c'est vous avec
vous même un qu'est ce que vous vous
dites quand vous venez sur un plateau de
tv il faut y aller ouais ouais c'est dur
non non non qu'est ce que vous vous
dites quand vous vous levez le matin
encore une belle journée
mais surtout j'ai fait gris
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous vous
entendez parler français
voilà qu'est ce que vous dites quand on
vous reconnaît pas dans la rue
pierrot des poteaux non
non non et j'ai connu la gloire à 14 ans
à 22 ans je ne pouvais plus c'est pour
ça que je suis venu en france donc quand
on méconnaît pas dans la rue ça veut
dire que je peux encore être voyeur
c'est ça qui me plaît
coquine c'est là qu'est ce que vous
dites quand vous vous regardez dans un
miroir
j'étais gier mais heureusement que des
puits à non un truc comme ça je vois
plus bien sa lunette non à leurs
attentes à la fin il était au top et
tous ça lasse pas tâche des gardiens
tu as bien prévu les choses parce que
vous enviez on se voit on se voit pas ce
qu'est voilà
bien joué mais on a des problèmes tu vas
insidieux je ne suis pas acculer parce
que je n'ai pas vu
wouah ici j'avais pas vu comment vous
est coiffé là par exemple non si
j'écoute les cheveux non je plaisante et
richard mais ici c'est ici que mon
parfum j'étais bien ce que je suis
sortie n'avait tout qu'est ce que vous
vous dites qu'on vous retrouvez seul le
soir je me trouve pas seuls les soldes
et puis quoi encore qu'est ce que vous
dites quand vous avez envie d'abandonner
ce métier
je sais pas faire autre chose pour moi
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
regarder le journal télévisé à mon corps
un corps qu'est ce que vous dites quand
vous jouez à poil
rendre les ventres
d'ailleurs les autres
je fais des faits tu maintenant donc il
faut un tour entre elles viennent plus à
l'est il faut les coller et tout le
reste c'est de s'y perdre est détendue
conquis qui conquit qu'ont donc tout ça
bien duel avec des débats du nom mais je
sais je connais cette technique que la
connaissent le magnifique n'y a que ça
qui est dur sur
cette voie là ok qu'est ce que vous
dites que je dois passer un garçon au
cinéma et qu'est ce que vous dites qu'on
vous embrasser un garçon hausse a dit
tu as très bien répondu non
eh
ben j'ai dit à sa maquillage de les
donner un swing
qu'est ce que vous dites que vous
embrasser une fille cinéma quinger vrai
appareil est ingrate à bienne
qu'est ce que vous dites que vous n'avez
pas confiance en vous elle pointe
chewing gum et non respect d'âge on
respire on respire et tout ça c'est du
mirage présent il n'y a aucune raison
que ça marche pas cette fois ci tu ne
respires à trois fois c'est juste un
mirage il n'y a aucune raison ouais
qu'est ce que vous dites que vous êtes
prête à tout casser
respire aussi parce que c'est beaucoup
mieux de pas là n'est pas tout casser
quand vous touchez la drogue qu'est ce
que vous direz spirou s'ils s'attaquent
aux puces plus la drogue d'ailleurs j'ai
arrêté
de fumer
a très bien cette nouvelle façon commune
écrit il ya des petits patrick dans une
petite rue quand j'ai vu des bulldogs
donc 2 à marcher
qu'est ce que vous vous dites que vous
voyez un mec canon canon tu veux dire
quoi canon le mécano à canon cameroun
empressé on a été quand même dominateurs
mais bon journal mais perd pied pendant
la ronde dans top gun n'ont laissé
voyez souvent tu te vois souvent en ce
sens qu est ce que vous vous dites quand
vous tromper nicolas g 30 jamais nicolas
achètent du vin le seul mais violent là
et on marcel guillaume et violent
l'année programmes télévisés comme toi
on peut y arriver des sages un an mais
non mais non voilée a pas de geste
tu vois ce que je vais dire non j'adore
je laime sais c'est l'amour de ma vie ah
ouais si il ya le match tout laissait
très bien que moi j'y suis et mon orama
ça veut dire partout en espagne les
grains pas je vais sérieusement victoria
il est mieux que gérard
elle va écouter
et non il est pas non il est pas mieux
que gérard gérard c'est lé père de mes
enfants c'est sacré ça et ça est ce
qu'il veut lui qu'un retour aux cartes
aux dents partout non car tout le
premier emploi cet imbécile
c'est la dernière chose qui m'a dit
c'est un imbécile vous a fait ça fait 20
ans que je les vois pas un nafaqa peu
s'étaient séparés ou des 3,4 en europe
je mets les rencontres ivre morte mois à
6 heures du matin entre n'est sortie
d'une discothèque en donc ton qu'ils
m'arrêtent il me dit est ce que tous en
espagne en clair à temps il est
tellement deuxième langue alors
il met 10 es tu veuilles mairie garde
seront sûrement j'étais un petit peu
moins de plus comme on est quand on a
maintenant on a bien bien danser
bienvenue et la présidente bien entendu
quoi donc il met dix sept ans fera qu'en
ce lundi donc et stages massacra tu sais
tu es plus tu vas pas le pas freiné un
peu plus cette démarche est il de la
digos des rires c'est ce que je vous dis
oui je suis marqué tellement jerry
douala et tout de suite après j'ai
commencé à monter les escaliers pour
très bientôt le bien et j'étais ravi du
hockey les bonnes réponses j'étais ravi
des mois et tu dois plus qu'ils aient
pas rentrer dans un truc à bosser
platanes on n'a plus jamais revu à
retour au 2 mai
mais faire ça je vis a plus jamais à
temps
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou